[Música]
Hola Esto es África 7 días el magazine
donde les presentamos la actualidad del
continente africano estos son los
titulares el mundial ha comenzado en
esta edición hablamos de las
posibilidades de los equipos africanos
nuestro cronista deportivo Rodrigo
sedano nos acompaña la co27 que tuvo
lugar en Egipto a terminado para muchos
activistas africanos sus conclusiones no
estuvieron a la altura de los retos y de
las expectativas en el este de la
República democrática del Congo la
situación sigue siendo tensa los
insurgentes del grupo armado m23 y el
ejército congoleño llevan semanas
enfrentándose el ex presidente de Kenia
osguró keniata quien es facilitador en
el conflicto anunció que Ruanda aceptó
pedir a los Rebeldes del m23 que
depusieran las armas tenemos informe
abrimos Este programa con deporte la
Copa del Mundo inicio en Qatar y 32
equipos competirán Durante un mes entre
ellos cinco equipos africanos senegal
Marruecos Camerún túnez y gana Qué
posibilidades tienen estos equipos para
analizarlo estamos con nuestro cronista
deportivo Rodrigo sedano Rodrigo
bienvenido África 7 días Muchas gracias
una gran invitación para este programa
Entonces vamos a hablar de las
posibilidades de los equipos africanos
en este mundial pero primero empezamos
con La decepción de todo un país senegal
con la ausencia de la Estrella salió
Mané desde luego una gran decepción para
la propia selección y como bien has
indicado para todo un país que se queda
sin su gran estrella salió Mané en la
selección la verdad que esperaban que
pudiera quizás jugar al final del torneo
pero tuvo que ser intervenido
quirúrgicamente y se despidió de este
mundial de Qatar Y es que es un re total
en el campo para senegal debutó a los 20
años con la selección y es el máximo
goleador histórico y Máximo Faro de este
equipo en la anterior copa de África de
la cual son campeones pero la
importancia de su figura va además mucho
más allá nacido en una familia Pobre
manera destinado parte de su dinero a
construir un hospital escuelas y ayudar
a los más pobres de la misma región en
la que se crió lo que ha provocado que
su figura sea muy querida en todo el
país de hecho nuestra corresponsal en
Dakar Sara saco pudo comprobar en
persona lo que sienten los senegaleses
tras la lesión de Mané
yo no me apetece ver los partidos del
Mundial lo juro sin sadio Mané y no soy
el único que lo piensa ayer lo
hablábamos con amigos algunos habían
comprado un televisor pero ya lo van a
devolver porque esa diomaneno va a jugar
que le pase solo humana tenemos más
futbolistas aparte de estadio Mané sigo
confiando en que van a tener una mejor
competición que en 2002 que ya fue muy
buena pienso que los leones pueden
llegar hasta
pues desde luego tiene senegal muchos
más jugadores que se ha dio Mané como
comentaban estos aficionados ha habido
refuerzos por parte de los jugadores que
juegan en Europa por ello todavía hoy
hemos visto que no han tenido un gran
resultado contra Países Bajos en el
primer partido de este mundial pero
pueden jugar bien ellos realmente tienen
que ver si pueden ganar a Ecuador lo que
tiene que ser su principal meta para
poder clasificar a octavos creo que si
no clasifican adaptados sería una
decepción
sí Rodrigo le deseamos lo mejor a la
selección senegalesa pese a la ausencia
de Sayo Mané ahora Rodrigo nos puede
explicar Cuáles son las posibilidades
reales de las de los equipos africanos
sus posibilidades de clasificación en
este mundial Pues realmente es senegal
la que tiene más posibilidades de
clasificar Más allá de la clase de la
fase de grupos en este mundial tiene un
equipo sólido como decía anteriormente
el resultado contra Países Bajos no es
bueno pero deben centrarse en ganar a
Ecuador porque
Qatar a priori no es rival para ellos
diría que sería otra vez repito una
decepción no verlos en octavos diferente
es sin embargo la situación de Marruecos
que no tiene mal equipo como se vio en
la copa de África donde perdió un
cuartos de final contra la subcampeón
Egipto pero que se encuentra
probablemente en el grupo más difícil
del mundial con Croacia y con Bélgica a
priori luchará con Canadá por no ser
última de este grupo similar papel le
espera a túnez que está en el grupo de
Francia y junto a dinamar de Australia
tendrá difícil clasificar en el grupo en
el grupo G juega Camerún la selección
africana más veterana del mundial que
también tiene un grupo complicado con
Brasil muy potente y una Serbia a la que
muchos auguran un buen papel realmente
en este mundial nos queda gana que
realmente sí que puede hacer un buen
papel en Qatar es el equipo con la media
de edad más joven pero se ha reforzado
con figuras como el español de
ascendencia ganesa iñaki Williams que
por cierto su hermano jugará con España
y no es un grupo fácil con Portugal y
Uruguay dos equipos fuertes pero tienen
posibilidades será bonito el partido
contra Uruguay hay que apuntarlo
selección que les privó de llegar a
semifinales en el mundial de 2010 hasta
ahora su mejor recorrido en un mundial
si Rodrigo y quisiera terminar con un
dato que me parece muy importante y es
que por primera vez 5 dirige coach
dirigentes locales dirigen a estos
equipos Sí la verdad que es un hito
desde 1930 que empezaron los mundiales
nunca había pasado algo así el último en
incorporarse ha sido el nuevo entrenador
de Marruecos y con ello pues llegamos a
un momento quizás a un momento de
impasse para África es verdad que han
tenido ciertos buenos resultados con
algunos entrenadores europeos pero los
entrenadores africanos conocen mejores
las dinámicas de los fútbol de los
diferentes tipos de fútbol en las
diferentes ligas y en los diferentes
países Así que seguro que será un punto
muy importante para el fútbol en África
Rodrigo Muchas gracias por estar con
nosotros en África 7 días
cambiamos de tema y pasamos a la cop 27
la conferencia mundial sobre el clima
celebrada en charme change Egipto ha
terminado tras intensas negociaciones
las distintas delegaciones de todo el
mundo llegaron a un acuerdo con un fondo
para los países más vulnerables por las
pérdidas y daños causados por las
catástrofes naturales pero las
conclusiones de esta Cumbre dejaron a
muchos participantes del continente
africano
insatisfechos escuchemos a Mohamed Adobe
director del grupo de reflexión sobre
energía y clima powershift África habló
con nuestra India de especial Marina
Colorado antes de que la conferencia
entregue sus conclusiones
es un poco decepcionante teniendo una
joven en el continente más vulnerable
uno esperaría que el mundo ayudará a
apoyar a África pero también a las
regiones vulnerables asegurándose de
realmente ofrecer un apoyo adecuado para
la adaptación y también Establecer un
fondo para las pérdidas y los daños que
ayude efectivamente a las naciones
vulnerables a acceder a la financiación
necesaria para poder hacer frente a los
impactos de las catástrofes climáticas
Aunque parece que al final tendremos un
mecanismo de pérdidas y daños algunas de
las condiciones que han puesto hacen que
sea difícil acceder a él Y
lamentablemente no se conseguirá la
escala de cambio que se necesita
seguimos con el tema del clima y vamos a
Costa de Marfil el país quiere
convertirse en el centro energético de
África occidental con la creación de la
mayor central de biomasa de la región la
planta producirá electricidad para miles
de ciudadanos veamos el informe de Sofi
lamod y sayamanyo
residuos de hojas de palma para crear
electricidad en Costa de Marfil Esta es
la promesa de la futura central de
biomasa que se está construyendo aquí en
la ciudad de iguazú en el sureste del
país cuya finalización está prevista
para 2024 quemará 500 mil toneladas de
residuos de Palma a combustión creará
vapor de agua que luego producirá
electricidad
nacional
utilizamos la biomasa que es residuo
natural de la agroindustria y está
disponible en gran abundancia en este
país esto permite producir 350
gigavatios hora de Electricidad al año y
si lo traducimos al número de personas
podemos abastecer a 1.7 millones de
personas gracias a esta planta
son argumentos que atraen a los
inversores climáticos especialmente en
la Unión Europea el proyecto es una
vitrina de importancia para el país
aquí en Costa de Marfil hay potencial
para de transición energética podemos
contemplar la posibilidad de invertir en
energía renovables hay potencial Para
aprovechar todas las oportunidades de
ser más eficientes en términos de
consumo energético social
quiere aumentar hasta el 42% el
porcentaje de energías renovables en su
mix energético que en la actualidad es
mayoritariamente térmico para este
experto en energía este Reto Ya se está
cumpliendo de ella
cosa de Marfil ya está en el camino de
las energías renovables la transición es
un proceso que sigue objetivos en
particular el de alcanzar más del 50%
para 2030 Costa de Marfil produce
principalmente energía térmica e
hidráulica que vende a los países
vecinos si esta transición energética
tiene éxito el país podría convertirse
en el centro energético de toda África
occidental una actua funciona ahora de
la situación en el este de la República
democrática del Congo donde los
insurgentes del grupo Rebelde m23 y el
ejército congolenio han estado luchando
durante semanas el m-23 se encuentra a
pocos kilómetros de goma la capital de
la provincia la República democrática
del Congo acusa a su vecino Ruanda de
apoyar a los Rebeldes para encontrar una
salida diplomática a la crisis el
expresidente de Kenia ujuro keniata está
actuando como facilitador anunció que el
presidente ruandes polkagame había
aceptado unirse con los a los llamados
internacionales para que los Rebeldes
del m23 se requieren de los territorios
que ocupan los detalles con nuestra
corresponsal en quigalí Maria amcone
este anuncio del presidente Irlandés no
es una sorpresa porque desde la
reaparición del grupo armado en 23 que
galí siempre ha hecho saber que Haría
todo lo posible para llevar la paz a la
gestión pero en realidad las relaciones
diplomáticas entre Ruanda y la República
democrática del Congo no han hechos más
que editorial ser con los eventos cada
vez más violentos la última fue esta
semana cuando un soldados congoleño
cruzó la frontera holandesa Sí
motorización y madrugada y disparó a los
soldados holandeses los mataron a tiros
antes que pudiera causar víctimas aquí
en que Galy este acontecimientos y
percibí como una provocación adicional
por parte de kinshasa por su parte la rc
no deja de denunciar el apoyo de Ruanda
a el 23 Ruanda siempre lo han negado a
pesar de las acusaciones de un informe
de un grupo de expertos de la ONU y
mientras los dos países acusan
mutuamente el grupo armado en 23 sigue
engañado terreno ahora está apenas 20
kilómetros de goma la capital de la
provincia
esto ha hecho tener una nueva ocupación
de la ciudad más importantes del este de
la rc como ocurrió hace 10 años según la
ONU desde el 20 de octubre más de
200.000 personas ha visto desplazados
por los combates entre el grupo Rebeldes
de 23 el ejército congoleño así
terminamos la edición de esta semana
Gracias a nuestra jefa de edición
Jennifer Guevara y gracias a ustedes por
acompañarnos
[Música]